when you think space you probably think
one space agency that travels under the
radar is issa
which is surprising considering what the
european space agency has achieved and
how vital it is to the global space
industry
we've collaborated with pretty much
everybody who is involved in space
exploration
wants to be a leading force in
furthering humanity's mission into space
for the first time we're playing a key
role in a human space flight mission
that goes beyond low earth orbit
if we want to have a successful human
missions to mars we are going to have to
learn to live and work off-world in a
different way
the place where we are going to learn to
do that is on the moon
in a world where working together seems
to be getting more and more difficult
can issa help humanity take its next
giant leap
established in 1975 esa touches most
corners of europe
unlike other agencies it's a diverse
collective
the european space agency is an
intergovernmental organization with 22
member states from europe the core to
ease of success is that international
collaboration
its formative years were mainly spent
working in conjunction with nasa and its
record in space is pretty special
from launching the world's first high
orbit telescope and studying comets up
close
perhaps its most famous mission was
launched with nasa in 1990 we joined
with nasa to build the hubble space
telescope and of course that's been
flying now for more than 30 years
hubble has since discovered more distant
objects than any terrestrial instrument
in 2003 issa launched the mars express
orbiter the first fully european mission
to a planet
since then there's been the farthest
landing from earth made on saturn's moon
titan and the first robotic landing on a
comet
easter has also invested in earth
observation satellites
telecommunications and even built
europe's own gps system but its
astronauts haven't journeyed beyond the
400 kilometer orbit of the international
space station
we've never played a key role until now
in human exploration
beyond low earth orbit
but with the artemis mission which will
enable us to send humans back to the
moon for the first time esa is a central
part of that esa has built the service
module of the orion crew vehicle
and
the nasa and esa astronauts that will
ride on that capsule to the moon will be
powered by european technology
in 2019 esa ministers committed to its
biggest ever budget and approved an
ambitious portfolio of space programs
while esa cannot compete with the likes
of nasa when it comes to spending esa
provides valuable science services that
have made it an essential partner in
nasa's artemis programme
esa will contribute habitation and
refueling modules along with enhanced
communications
it'll also be responsible for operating
elements on the lunar gateway a
permanent station in orbit around the
moon
the lunar gateway has two functions
really
it's the first place
that humans will go to live and work for
extended periods beyond earth's orbit so
we're really exposing humans to a
location which is in deep space where
the environment and the conditions are
very different from what we find on the
space station this gives us a test bed
somewhere to learn how to live and work
in deep space for long periods of time
it's also somewhere where we can perform
scientific research
which will prepare us for future
exploration in deep space
we're also working on a large lunar
lander which would take cargo logistics
robotics and other equipment to the
surface of the moon as a contribution to
the human missions that are going to
follow during the 2020s
the first
human missions to go return to the
service of the moon are planned for the
latter part of this decade
those could be followed by the build-up
of infrastructure and capability so we
could be seeing a sustained presence on
the moon into the 2020s
sustainability is going to be based on
having the infrastructure
and the facilities to enable long-term
access and if you want to do that on the
moon in a long-term sustainable way
we're going to have to learn to use the
resources that we find locally wherever
we can
if you can take the regolith the ground
up dusty rocky powder that we find at
the lunar surface if we can then bind
that together we can create structures
those structures can protect us from the
very hot and very cold environment so to
create some thermal shielding we can
also use it to create radiation
shielding and so it's regular 3d
printing where you take this stuff and
you 3d print it into the structures you
need is a really exciting technology for
future applications
gravity on the moon is much lower than
it is on earth so launching a rocket off
the lunar surface would potentially be
easier as it requires much less thrust
less thrust means less fuel making room
in the rocket for the essential payloads
to get humans to mars and beyond
the moon's polar regions also have large
supplies of water ice which could be
broken down into oxygen and hydrogen
useful ingredients needed for humans to
breathe and rockets to fly
this return to the moon will prepare us
for mars so we're going to be performing
cutting-edge science the like of which
has never been done before
humans last stepped onto the moon nearly
50 years ago now multiple nations
including china russia and india all
have planned missions
unlike the apollo missions which lasted
just days new missions would be much
longer because we now think the moon can
teach us so much more
off the coast of west africa lanzarote's
volcanic landscape might be the closest
thing to the lunar surface here on earth
it's why issa comes here to run its
pangaea program
a specialized international training
course for astronauts
some of the reasons that we're going to
go back to the moon are to look at very
early planetary system formation so we
can understand the earth moon system
[Music]
as well as europeans isa is training
nasa astronaut dr kate rubins
rubens has already spent 300 days in
space
but as part of nasa's artemis program
she's likely to become the first woman
to walk on the moon
it's very stark it's very volcanic
and that's actually similar to the moon
there are ancient volcanoes on the moon
even the regolith on the moon is this
kind of glassy volcanic rock that we see
here
you're looking at hundreds of millions
of years of time and our hope is to
discover some of these very very early
rocks possibly these rocks would be
thrown up through the magma near a
volcano so today we're taking the
physical samples of the rock and the in
the biology but we're also taking things
like spectra so we can we can shoot some
light at the rock and see what bounces
back at us and different minerals are
going to bounce back different spectral
patterns
the moon's a a fantastic laboratory for
understanding the solar system
unlike on earth where we have plate
tectonics we have an atmosphere we have
water
it just kind of destroys the rock record
a little bit on the moon we don't have
any of that so actually it's very much
like it was in its early history and in
fact people have talked about finding
parts of earth on the moon that are much
older than a lot of the rocks we can
find on earth and they're still in a
more pristine state because the the moon
hasn't had that that overturn that you
get on the earth commander
the pangaea training course isn't just
preparing these astronauts for the moon
it's training them to look for signs of
life that might be more likely elsewhere
in the solar system volcanic
environments look very barren on earth
there's rocks with no plants often
especially if they're very fresh
volcanic environments very new but in
reality actually there's a lot of
microbial life living in rocks and on
rocks and in all sorts of parts of of a
volcanic environment like you can see
around me so
understanding the places where the most
interesting biology is is very important
uh for training astronauts in terms of
what they should target when they go to
mars and also just for scientists to
understand where we should look for
searching for life on mars
this was a day where they were letting
us be autonomous so we were making some
of the discoveries like we would do on
the lunar surface so some of the things
that we were finding were very
interesting
was an area where there was some
possible maybe hydrothermal vents or
some water interaction coming up and we
could see some alterations in the
minerals so that kind of thing
would be incredibly important and very
valuable if we saw that on the on the
surface of mars this would be an example
of a place that you would stop and do a
lot of sampling for life
the other thing that's really important
is the context of the sample so we need
to know this isn't just a rock that we
plucked off the ground but where is it
is it close to the hot spring is it near
the volcano was it an early sample was
it a later sample all of that kind of
metadata is really critical in
understanding
that geobiology sample in the context of
everything else that was going on in the
environment
the moon could serve as a proving ground
for the technologies of the future
helping humanity learn how to live and
work in space and launch missions to
bodies further than ever before
like mars
if you look at the surface of mars
there's lots of channels that have been
carved by water early on in its its
history it was probably a very different
planet probably a lot more habitable
much more conducive to life potentially
there's a lot we can learn about what
biology is in terms of kind of a feature
of the universe we can learn by going to
mars because perhaps it was habitable
early but maybe life never developed so
we need to understand why that is or if
life developed how long it lasted there
maybe it was transferred to earth maybe
it was transferred from earth to mars so
there's all sorts of different questions
that could get answered by uh by
understanding more about about mars
in esa's planetary robotics lab in the
netherlands scientists maneuver a
half-scale version of the exomars rover
part of a mission due to launch in 2022
to date only nasa and china have landed
rovers on the red planet
joining them would be a coup freeza
along with several other high-tech
instruments the exomars rover will be
the first that can drill to a depth of 2
meters something that could deliver
groundbreaking science for the agency
we believe that material brought from
below the surface honks a better chance
to bring some interesting discoveries
because the samples would have been
basically protected by that depth
from the heavy radiation and the thermal
cycles that apply on the surface and
which maybe explain why so far the
samples taken over from the surface
didn't reveal anything very very
interesting the planet is not that far
from the sun
and therefore the temperature experience
on the planet are still adequate for the
development of life
the planet has also a kind of similar
origin and development as a planet earth
and therefore we can hope
to find traces of biological life
if we properly sound the soil of the
planet
rover was a difficult realization but i
believe we are there we mastered well
now the technology to do this sort of
vehicle
not only the vehicle but also the
integration of science instruments and
the realization of the laboratory and of
the drill which allows to to pick up the
samples from underneath the surface
issa has suffered setbacks with its mars
missions before so the stakes are high
for this mission issa is working with
roz cosmos the russian space agency is
providing the landing craft and the
rocket to deliver the european rover
russia's involvement came after nasa
said it could no longer fund the
purchase of two u.s atlas v rockets for
exomars
it serves as an example of what the
space industry can achieve through
bilateral exchanges most often seen on
the international space station
that's not to say partnerships are
always easy to manage
the evolution of the political world
today makes the setting of such
cooperation a bit more at risk if i take
the example of exomars the cooperation
was started at a point when the
relationship between europe and russia
were relatively satisfactory but those
relations have worsened enormously since
invasion by russia of crimea
in ukraine
and now we have basically to deal with a
partner which is much more attentive to
the way we deal with them
much more secretive on the information
they reveal
meaning that the risk level of their
deliverable is increasing for us and
waiting a lot on the chance of success
of the mission so
we have basically to take all those
parameters into account when setting a
corporation knowing that going alone uh
about those big complex mission is
something that so far we cannot afford
from a budgetary point of view so we
have still in any case to adopt
cooperative road to deliver big and
ambitious mission like the mission
landing over on mars
one of my favorite phrases is that space
may be a vacuum but it doesn't take
place in one meaning that politics are
of course an incredibly important part
of everything that we do
countries like china and india are
starting to challenge the us's position
as leaders in space technology and
exploration
competition which appears to be at odds
with esa's core collaborative mission
our take on the the old school space
race is that's kind of behind us the way
to achieve the big goals which phases
now whether that's looking down at the
earth or looking out into the universe
these are best done together
in space exploration at the moment i
think we see a coming together of two
things that are perhaps a little
different one is international
cooperation and the other is competition
i think different countries different
agencies different public and private
actors
are aiming to have their own capability
to access and operate at different
places in space and on the moon
as we build these different capabilities
we create competition it also drives
innovation it drives down costs and it
makes the space more accessible to
everybody so i think this is a very
positive thing
bringing together the value added of
working as a community in europe has
allowed us to achieve much more than any
country in europe could have achieved on
its own it's not just the sum of the
parts it's much greater than that
you